e
okay set so is the clerk ready to take
notes the clerk is ready the question is
oh okay good thank you do you know
anything about Senator
gray
okay yeah could
you yeah there was another meeting
across the hall but that that ended I
was there were two meetings across the
hall I was at the first were there
Senators there was also J Senator inis
was there and Senator graay was there oh
okay so so he's
nearby off to make a call or something
that meeting ended
about oh
right goty several minutes well we have
three that don't we have like three
okay is is the number assigned seven or
right yeah I think we're good with
stream okay all right all right let's
go okay thank you all right welcome
Senator rosenal so um let let's take a
look at the agenda
else um there is one thing that if we're
reviewing findings and
recommendations uh after the followup
from
natural uh and cultural resources and
treasure it be nice to have the treasure
and and natural and cultural resources
still
here that
I'm sorry I couldn't oh
sorry uh it'd be nice to have the
treasure and natural and cultural
resources still here when we're
reviewing findings since they've got an
today all right I I was kind of hoping
that the treasurer's
time we we could let her go after her
part
so but it's it's um up to her whether
she has time or
not okay fine all right um yeah if you
want to work on your phone or something
that's it's fine with me all right so
um any uh any other changes to the
minute to the agenda no no everyone in
favor say I I I okay any opposed okay so
we have an agenda all right I welcome uh
treasur mapelli
Madam Treasurer I
guess um I had a couple of question the
reason I asked her to come is um a
couple of things came up from our last
meeting that I had I sent her questions
and she sent responses but I thought
that maybe other members you know might
like to ask questions
also um so I'll just we'll just get into
what I asked and what you responded so
um if you remember the Dr
had a fund that was paying off their um
their new information system right so it
was the revenue information system
manage fund which was
um fund number 337 accounting unit
5773 and um it seemed like a weird fund
because it was just accumulating money
to get to $40
million um
but at the same time we've borrowed
money right so we're paying interest on
this borrowed money and we're
accumulating money and so I asked the
question of can't we you know pay off
these bonds early since we have this
extra money accumulating and um her
response
was we can't because when we Bond things
we don't just send out a bond for this
particular information system we send
out a bond for everything that the that
the state is borrowing and secondly that
when we make bonds they're not callable
for 10 years so we're committed to
paying off those bonds over 10 years
plus um and then
thirdly um the money when we have spare
money we're earning more interest on it
than we're paying interest on these
bonds so we wouldn't want to do it
anyways is all that
correct that is correct good morning uh
for the director State treasure Monica
mapelli that is correct so I was trying
to explain that um when we look at um
just one project or One Fund is not that
simple to separate uh the debt for just
that project um because we issue bonds
and we when we issue bonds we um gather
all of the eligible projects uh all the
project all of the agencies have spent
money on particular project so then we
say okay it's time to bond and so so we
grab those and those are the ones that
we fund we with the bond proceeds we pay
for those projects so so it's not that
simple to separate once in a while we do
have specifics and we're able to um
issue something in particular but for
the most part our general processes to
just uh um essentially just grab all
those projects and and and fund them
with the bond proceeds um we do on a
regular basis we do review what's cable
so um and when that when that happens we
have essentially the opportunity to try
to see if we if it makes sense to re
refund those bonds to to issue refund
and bonds um so so we'll have that
opportunity so we issue in general once
once a year we issue bonds so in general
um we'll do it in March again and during
that time we'll see uh bonds that have
reached that date to see if it feasible
if it makes sense to to issue refunding
bonds so that's sort of the process so
looking at just rims and spe
specifically
that rims fund was in house bille 25
when that was when that was uh enacted
it was um the plan the way the law was
written is that the general fund was
going to pay for6 million and then the
rest of the funding of the rest of like
24 million was going to come from this
additional Revenue that was going to be
generated from the system it was going
to be placed in this specific fund and
then the debts service was going to be
paid from that from those money so
that's why I believe it's okay that if
they just accumulate unfortunately we
can't just take the money and pay off
the bonds we just have to make sure
there is enough money when it's time to
pay that service that money comes from
the fund and not the general fund so we
take so um so we make sure that those
the bonds are being paid the portion
related to RS comes from that those
other
monies so Ros thank you thank you for
that for trying to make it at my level
but it's okay just have we been able to
generate higher
interest on those bonds then we need to
pay off the rims fund the rims expense
is there any I know we're limited to I
think it's 4 million a year or something
are we making more more money than we
fund so
um I don't fully understand the
methodology of what gets recorded in
that fund I believe there's a
methodology Dr puts it together so
um in terms of paying the bonds I think
the intent of the law was to make sure
there was enough money in there to pay
the debt service where there is more
right now that should be is is is is
really uh difficult for me to answer um
what I know is that fund by itself
doesn't earn interest as you know we
pull all of the cash on the funds that
earn interest
are that's that's that's written in law
so if there's a dedicated fund entitled
to our interest is specifically written
the law and those are the ones that when
we when we look at all the interest that
we earn then we need to see all of the
funds that have an interest um that
entitled to receive interest and then we
allocate interest so for example the
rims fund does not get interest so the
general fund keeps that portion um so
that was also part of your question why
can for example even the money uh
why isn't that uh receiving interest is
because it wasn't written a lot that it
that interest is cred to that
appropriation I believe that was just an
appropriation from the last ban
and so it's just sitting there so if
it's sitting there we're investing the
money and the state is earning money um
in terms of the interest rates um we've
been in in a an environment we've been
able to earn higher interest because of
you know the higher interest rates in
the short term the long term have have
been pretty consistent at about 4% so
those are typically normally those are
higher interest rates but because of the
different interest interest right
environment that we've been uh
experiencing um we've been benefiting
from having all this cash and then
earning we've been earning interest
that's going to change it's going to go
back to long-term interest rates are
going to be higher than shortterm so but
right now while we go through the
process that's going to occur over the
next two years right now we're earning
more interest with those funds that are
sitting
there you're welcome so right now we're
paying like 4% and earning five or
okay but it's going into the general
fund it is going to the general fund if
it if the law doesn't say that those
funds uh get interest then the the
general fund is getting all of that
right that's what you see in the um
Revenue Focus all right so how about the
management of of the Dr fund should that
be in your office instead of theirs
because it didn't seem
like they knew much about it except that
they are putting money into it sort of
right I think it's more of an accounting
transaction I mean that they just handle
the accounting again we pull all the
cash we do we invest all of the funds so
um regardless of where the funds are
being recorded what agency has it we we
we handle all the cash ourselves so in
essence we are managing the fund and
then when it's time to allocate interest
then we look at all those individual
funds of all of the agencies and then we
all right uh yes represent of
all yes I'm sorry Dr a isn't here I
think um but
um what happens at the end of the period
when we've got 40 thou 40 million in in
that account if that is more than is
needed to finish paying off the bonds um
does it go directly to General funds I
believe so I think the law considered
that that piece um I can find a
reference in the Statue I think it was
either
um it's in that the the rims law that
says if there's access fund it can go
back to the general
fund
um so if they at that point needed to do
some kind of update which they think is
going to be rare because we don't have
sales and income taxes um
then on they'd have to start over again
getting it out of the
budget right so so right here is uh is s
say
21j um column 1B paragraph 3 it does
talk about sending the excess money to
thanks right and then the other question
I asked there was about um uh fund
number 104 accounting unit 3 3705 the
Canon Mountain Capital Improvement fund
it's it's it's used to make improvements
to the ski area and we've borrowed as I
remembered something like $6
million over over the years and so
they're paying
you know those are borrowed monies and
they're paying off the debt but at the
same time we also borrowed like we also
allocated something like 18 million to
help Canam Mountain replace their tram
and they're still trying to find a
vendor and doing other stuff so my
question
was um since the 18 million is sitting
there earning interest and since you
know we've borrowed 6 million for
essentially similar purposes should we
just pay that off but the the answer was
we can't and we shouldn't because
because of the interest difference um
but the other question and and she she
touched on it was maybe the interest on
the $18 million that's sitting around
ought to go to this fund whereas right
now it's going to the general fund it is
and I just I I went to um it was House
Bill 2 uh where the funds were
appropriated it was just um 18 million
was appropriated and the the only the
only language added in that section was
that the funds are non lapsing so
there's silent on on interest so when we
again for us it's black and white if we
don't see it we don't allocate interest
um to something that is silent um and it
gets really difficult right now we have
interest to allocate but it was very
difficult when it was uh absolutely not
we weren't earning any interest those
years
so okay so I would just suggest that
maybe we to that non-aps and we say an
interest is credited to the fund or
something like that how however I don't
believe this is a dedicated fund this is
just an
appropriation um that says It's Not
absent but it's not a typical oh it's
not a dedic it's not a typical dedicated
fund that is listed in irsi 12 this is
just an appropriation that is not
lapsing money I go you that's my
understanding all right Senator Rosell
well um I recall from last week we had a
lot of discussion about the difference
between Canon
Mountain as part of the ski area and
Fran coni and N State Park and they seem
to be
different um the tram I think mostly
functions mostly
brings visitors in the summer rather
than during the ski season it operates
in the winter but it's really more of a
summer and fall draw so
um it it does
system because it brings in so much
money well I'm not sure about that
because I mean isn't there for skiers
lift tickets and and they have to go up
the tram I mean how else do they no they
don't have to go up the trm excuse me
okay they we could
bring the experts here so all right
okay good morning Brian Wilson director
of division of Parks and Recreation uh
so for to to clarify the um the overall
Park fund is separated into various
accounts within the fund the ski area
count which is the operation of Canon
Mountain ski areas you you think of
winter operations but in the the tram is
part of the legislatively part of um uh
the the ski area account so uh it does
the tram
subsidizes uh the ski area overall
operation um they are very very
intertwined although the primary
ridership is taking place in the uh in
non non- winter season um just like like
any other ski area you know that Four
Season revenue is essential uh whether
it's you know lodging opportunities or
other uh um opportunities within the
venue to create Revenue outside of the
ski the W the short winter season uh is
really essential for us to sustain that
account if
that so my question is how do skiers get
to the top of the mountain so um there's
a number of lifts 10 10 or okay so there
are chair lifts and in in the winter
time the tram um does not operate um
every day um it's um partially its
weather uh conditions but generally on
uh Peak visitation you know vacation
weeks weekends um is is is when it's
operating so it's not it's not essential
uh to to the the skier experience but it
is an element that we do utilize uh
during the winter
time I didn't understand that
so right exactly I was thinking that's
how you get there to ski right but
apparently not so um so it's really more
like
sunap right it's a it's a separate
source of Revenue that happens you
know but but it's used by the by the
skier right except okay except okay
representative except it is owned by the
state and it is falling
apart so in that it is not like cipe at
all it's in danger of reducing the
amount of money available for the ski
area
sure
okay so let let me ask you for a number
how much revenue comes from the tram
every year uh uh gross revenue is uh
about $1.5 million uh directly
attributed to the tram now there's other
components to that we have retail and
Concession operations both at the base
and the summit of the tram facility that
aren't accessible by other means within
the skia so um when you start to include
those um ancillary revenue streams as
well too it it it it adds up to a
significant amount that all directly
area Senator gray and I take exception
to the words it's falling apart okay it
is costing more to maintain it and it's
reaching the end of its life which are
softer words but we don't want our our
visitors to think that they can't go on
the trm because it's falling apart good
mustard representative aling yeah and do
you have any idea what the significant
amount of concession money that's
attached to it
is um that that's in the in the hundreds
of thousands of dollars a few few
hundred thousands of dollars and and um
and again that's you know Four Season
Revenue so that's attributed to you know
what's going on at the park on any given
day for instance I was there yesterday
um at the park with our general manager
Jace worth who's here in the audience um
I just just a quick little antidote um I
did a just a cruise through the parking
lot um on a Tuesday there were uh
license plates from 33 different states
three different uh Canadian provinces
and one car from uh Estonia um so U it's
it's it's it's a very hling place here
during the and all of these things are
tied together folks are visiting The
Flume Gorge where encouraging them to go
up the road to go visit the tram and
vice versa so there there's a lot of
interconnectivity between the tram
operation and the summertime which is
supporting the ski area but also uh the
residual effects both from the parks uh
you know down the road at The Flume and
our campgrounds and everything that Fran
offer and presumably you could use an
extra 75,00
a month of interest on this $18
million that that that would be great we
can use every resource that we can for
uh for the park system yes okay y now
let's as long as you're here let's talk
about
um you have two different accounting
units in this one dedicated fund right
one for all the parks and one for the
ski area um would it be useful to have
two separate dedicated funds
I mean they would still essentially
operate the same way but um yeah I know
this came up a couple weeks ago and we
were we were here before you and I know
Chris Marino who's here is maybe perhaps
better to to to speak to that because
he's the one helping you know work work
our books I mean I think from from our
standpoint the structure from my
position the structure of the park
system is that these Al those separate
accounting units within the fund um were
created and we have the ability to
support each other in times of needs for
instance there's been years where Canon
has done really well in the park system
not so much and we have the ability to
move resources back and forth within the
fund uh to help bolster one one account
or another so if if some things like
that we're able to still sustain um I I
I would defer to to to Chris for some
guidance on
that yeah I'm happy to clarify Chris
Marino natural cultural resources and
yes I do recall this coming up and this
is related to uh number 33 fund number
33 which the the number 33 captures two
components of the entire park system so
on the one hand you have the Canon
Mountain scary account which is a
component of the broader Park fund and
then you have the multiple accounting
units that comprise the state park
account which is the other sort of half
of the entire park fund so I understand
it's seems a little confusing but there
are two distinct accounts within that
Park fund
so to to answer your question yeah I
think it would it would be probably make
sense to go ahead and separate those
into two separate uh itemized account
numbers under under under RSA 612 um
we're happy to do that and um
we would if it would be helpful we're
we're certainly supportive of
that name thank you all right other
representative Al me yeah sorry could
you remind me of your name again I'm
clarking I apiz my name is Chris Marino
Marino yes thank you Senator gray on oh
did you have Senator yeah I just wanted
to say that it it sounds in the books as
if we're talking just about Canan
Mountain not about the entire Park
Service which is what actually 333b
is I agree yes right so we could have a
more a better title yes Senator Grant uh
again the end of your statement confused
me a little do you want two separate
dedicated funds or just two accounting
units under the one dedicated
fund we we maintain two dedicated fund
accounts uh we should have two dedicated
fund accounts in this case we are
technically creating them separately we
have the Canon Mountain dedicated fund
which is the ski account fund and we
have the multi account state park fun uh
account which which is the other half of
the park fund but they both have number
they're both assigned the same dedicated
fund number so we'd want to separate
those and make those distinct dedicated
fund numbers to establish them clearly
as separate dedicated
funds so in my opinion that would be
appropriate for this but the tram
interest would not be appropriate for
the bill that this comp is going to do
because it is not a dedicated fund it's
just I need to be added to one of the
dedicated funds so if you want to add
interest or language related to interest
you want to do it on a fund that has a
balance because again we just Creed an
interest and we look at the balances at
the end of the quarter um so we want to
make sure there is a balance in one of
those dedicated FS right and there is a
dedicated fund that's borrowed the $6
million for Canon uh related
maintenance right
so that would be the appropriate fund I
would think yeah if I may um so that
dedicated cam was again similar to the
rims it was created uh back in 1998 to
um so so the the the capital Improvement
fund is unique is it is a revolving fund
is is a revolving Fund in a way that you
have um there is this authority to bond
on a regular basis up to $6 million so
it's very unique than all of the capital
projects that are bonded by the state
because those go through House Bill 25
this particular Authority is very unique
so in order to so so so um K man has the
ability to um on a regular basis borrow
money and just if there is if there is
capacity they can keep borrowing uh and
repay those funds so that dedicated
account is to uh maintain s Revenue the
revenue from sop and with that The Debt
Service gets paid that's how the
language is
written so I'm not really sure you want
to add interest to that you
you could I'm not sure yeah if I may
just just to if I'm understanding what
you're suggesting is essentially you're
suggesting diverting the interest that
is being earned on the $18 million which
talking about that to divert that to
support the additional paying of The
Debt Service against this Canon Mountain
Capital Improvement fund so it' be money
to support payoff of The Debt Service in
addition to the SOP Revenue that comes
in is that capsules caps what we're
talking okay yeah we're very supportive
of that idea because it's
really we allocated this 18
million for Canon right I mean it's not
really for uh for the tram I mean but
it's not really for the general fund
right so it's for the it's to support
the tram but as the treasure has has
pointed out a language is silent on
doing anything with any interest earned
on that in that case because there is
nothing
specifically prescribing what to do with
the interest that is earned from that
funds it stays within the general and
maybe by the time we could get a bill
done You' you will have already spent it
on the tram right so I don't know is
that
I suppose anything's possible I couldn't
speak to that okay in six months well I
don't know how close is the contract to
being signed and all that we
are we are probably uh i' I'd say at
least another two years out uh um um and
that's you know where're we're kind of
in between a a place here where we've
already bid the projects and uh that
cost came in well over the $18 million
so we're we're still kind of in a in a
in a gap here of trying to um understand
through this next budget cycle hopefully
where what direction we're going to be
going Senator
Ros it it I think it makes sense to keep
Canon
Mountain um and frankonia Notch State
Park separate
from other Parks because they're parks
that also charge charge fees that get
approved by fiscal so they they have
another Revenue source and um some of
most of our state parks I don't think
charge even for parking
but every year we
approve fees for usage of both camping
in Franconia Notch and skiing at Canon
so it it seems to me to make sense to
separate those fonts from the rest of
the park system all right thank
you other comments okay yes represent of
Al me I didn't hear you discussing that
option at
all to take
33 and separate it into three parts as I
understand it one which would
be the ski area one which would be
Franconia Notch and one which would be
every other Park in the
state okay uh just to clarify it would
it would only be a division of two not
three franconian Notch State Park
although residing at the same location
as Canon mountain is captured already in
the state park account component yeah
which is the other half so it would
already be included Ed so therefore two
two would be would be fine to capture
everything
properly Senator rosal's okay with that
I see you're nodding okay all right um
other questions for uh Treasurer
metell I seeing none thank you very much
all right um so I think the next thing
on our agenda was uh the um Connecticut
Lakes three fund you were going to get
that and in the book let's
221 there
for
start
all and in the
report
29 I'm not sure we in their
report oh here we go so yeah so in the
report that they sent us it's page 21 of
go all right thank you so do we have did
really if I may there there hasn't been
any additional uh information
information or any handouts however I
did invite the treasurer to join us
today to answer any specific questions
you had about the funds that you're
inquiring about um okay to the extent
that we could elaborate a little bit on
your understanding of these funds is
that's what I understood was oh okay
well I wanted to know there's an
endowment right so so isn't there there
are three three end there are three
endowments but there should be you know
this one has $3 million that one as 12
million you know whatever the numbers
yeah that's correct yeah okay is that
what you'd like to discuss that's what
we'd like to know yeah um so i' to inv
Madame
Treasurer um well I've I've invited the
deputy treasur chief Treasurer Rachel uh
I worked with her to uh yeah clarify uh
an understanding of how we're
maintaining these and she is could I to
help us also I'm sorry where did this
endowment come from
and do they have strings
still so the endowment came from a the
acquisition there was there was land
that was acquired and this is a this is
a document that gives a background uh
going back to
2003 um this air was managed um by the
New Hampshire Fish and Game
department and the state of New
Hampshire required a comprehensive
conservation easement of1 146,000 400
Acres um along with
that um established three separate
endowments to
benefit uh both dncr and the fishing
game in the management of this of this
area so there were three end three
endowments established each with a
principal
balance um one was referred to as the
monitoring endowment uh one was referred
to as a stewardship
endowment um and the third was a road
maintenance endowment um each having
their own principal amounts as
prescribed in in chapter law 2002
chapter 148 laws of
2002 um so those were established as
endowments with principal amounts under
this under the authority prescribed in
law at the time since that time those
funds are held in these endowments by
the
treasury who uh invests manages and so
forth and over a period of time
we are eligible to draw from these
endowments on a periodic basis certain
amounts uh within limits as allowed to
use the funds to administer the
stewardship uh authorities that were
prescribed as for the purpose of these
endowments so that is essentially
fundamentally where these endowments
come from and what their purpose is how
they were established does that answer
the question for you so it was entirely
essentially all right so let's start
with the first one uh number
219 so I'm guessing this has a balance
of a million dollar or something like
that so 219 in the book that would be
the uh contic the heads track monitoring
endowment and the track monitoring
endowment started with a principal
balance of 1.25 5
3747 and of course has grown
substantially in that time um so it
currently does have an ending
balance right
now
so is there any reason why that can't be
on this
report um so it can be on the report
representative I had a conversation with
the com controller actually this morning
so this report has always been designed
to
depict the states what what they call
their Ledger balances um so essentially
the report is only showing you as you as
you I'm sure you've
surmised what we're spending and
obviously the draws from the fund to pay
for it so gives no insight as you
obviously into these These funds
themselves what we can do is we can
expand the narrative component of this
report to
elaborate to include that additional
information so that you have a broader
understanding as you read this this
report to understand in terms of the
activity on the table what you're seeing
is the ins and you're seeing the the
amount being expended and of course the
draw to cover it but we can elaborate
with a separate uh part of this report
to clarify that information so you
understand the beginning ending balance
of this endowment and any additional
information related to it I just a
moment so why was the revenue only
$5,600 if you have $3 million
invested in this particular endowment
this is the track monitoring endowment
which is the least active of the three
endowments uh that's essentially what
that what that indicates is there was
just very little
activity occurring relative to the
monitoring of the tra monitoring that
was necessary oh are you saying the $3
million is the sum of the three the the
$3 million no is is the value of the
Endowment for this specific
purpose however yes there was only
$5,600 actually spent out of the
endowment out of the $3 million
Endowment in total um due to very little
activity related to the need to um all
right so is is $3 million there for
monitoring compliance yes the $3 million
that is in that account right now is
specifically uh established for the
purpose of track monitoring which
encompasses you know um right and
stewardship is yet another some some
stewardship is another are another one
and road maintenance the other yes that
is correct all right thank you
representative Aly yes um um at least
the last time I heard the AG's office
was and a lot of other people were
heavily involved in uh in
protecting that particular
monitoring endowment that is that the
the the new owner of a large tract
within there was trying had come in with
the intention of turning the whole place
Place into a permanent forest with no
logging and no pretty much nothing else
uh so that he could get CR re not Reggie
credits credits from the the uh the
national um anti uh climate
mitigation project and
um and that was being a opposed by quite
a lot of people that live
on
timbering in that area and by the fact
that the endowment itself the the
easement specifies that a certain amount
of logging is going to go on in every
year and that a certain amount of of uh
Sports Recreation is going to go on and
every year in the whole track on who
who's paying for for the AG's office Etc
is that not not an expense that should
be in there so I'm I'm going to defer
any clarifications to the commissioner
she's obviously heavily involved Ching
at the bit to talk about
this Sarah Stewart commissioner of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources
so there was an easen
established 20 years ago the state paid
$20 million for that um so um a very
substantial investment to ensure Public
Access Hunting Fishing uh Recreation Etc
um on this uh amazing track of land um
and over the past 20 years there's been
several sales and purchases of the the
fee owner of that land and um and over
the years that land has been uh
harvested for Timber successfully the
easement does not
include um a a minimum um amount of of
logging it only it the conversation at
the time around the easement was so
focused on we don't want to see this
property clearcut that they established
a ceiling um but not a not a
floor um and so we we are still in the
process of receiving public comment
we've had several public meetings
um my agency and Fish and Game are
working closely with our um attorneys
that are already provided to us for a
number of reasons um from the AG's
office so this is just part of their
portfolio of work um so they're not
being we're not billing there's no
billing for their um investment of time
to understand the easement and to work
with us and Aurora which is the fee
owner um to make sure their uh
stewardship plan for this property is in
line with the easement and so over the
last several months we've been
um we've been negotiating might be too
strong a word in conversations with them
they've submitted uh a draft plan that's
public uh the public comment closes on
Friday we have a meeting up up in
Pittsburgh um on Friday a regularly
scheduled meeting at the close of that
meeting
you know we'll evaluate the public
comment and get back to Aurora and and
there'll be some more iterations of that
plan before the state is in a position
to approve it but there will there still
is logging on the property there is a
lot of rumors out there that there isn't
there still is and we're committed to
that tradition and economic uh support
for the
region follow up go ahead yeah uh the so
the cost of all of this is is is found
inside of your general administrative
costs
yeah and the AG's office
is not financially involved shall we say
they're just our advisors um as they are
for many of our issues uh in this agency
Firm all right well so my main thing is
I don't think this report is is
acceptable you know this page 147 149
150 because it should be reported just
like any other F fund right there should
be a balance which went from 1.25
million to 3 million there should be
Revenue which is the actual revenue on
that amount there should be expenses
which are the actual expenses you're
reporting as though the revenue and the
expenses are equal well they're not
right the fund is growing so so you know
can can you get us new reports
absolutely and and I'll be I will be
like I said I spoke with the com
controller this morning we're going to
work to revise the report to give you
that additional information to be seen
on these reports um so that we go beyond
just the basic Ledger requirements which
which this is a depiction of and give
you a true understanding of of what
these endowments are how much what their
value is even a history of what has been
drawn from them and the earnings and so
forth so we will work to uh revise these
right so if for example you decided you
needed a major monitoring project right
to put cameras all over the place or
something like that then there's some
money here to do it and you wouldn't
have to come to us to say Alec give me
some more you know borrow money or
general fund money or something for this
project right yes and that's typically
how we've managed the support of the
conc headquarters Rel relative to these
to these endowments okay thank you
representative thank you but
on my impression is that when we get
this that on very small percentage of
the money in that particular endowment
would be being
used uh
whereas from the
reports
the endowment that is to maintain the
roads is feeling quite
underfunded and
the the other one I'm
not not so sure of the Endowment for
habitat and public use management which
seems to overlap with roads all right
let's go on to any more questions about
stu um
monitoring no okay let's go on to the
next one which is
um stewardship this is
um management what is the next one
habitat stewardship Ste is one way of
putting it but they also say another one
is
stewardship yeah
well there's monitoring there's
stewardship and there's roads right so
let's go to the stewardship correct so
stewardship uh again was also
established as a $1 million principal
amount uh for the purpose of habitat and
public use management of 25,000 Acres of
natural areas owned by the state of New
Hampshire and for the purpose of
recreation use and the conservation
easement management of the 146,00 Acres
on which the state shall hold a
conservation easement so again it was
another endowment established with a
specific purpose in mind and it has been
time and the current value the current
value on that
one Swit one
2.6 2613 million yes two $2.6 million
okay so this one is healthy I guess yes
okay all right questions on this no all
right I I just represent well me I find
is so overlapping stewardship includes
monitoring stewardship
includes uh all the rest of this stuff
and yeah to call any part of it
stewardship is representative I I I'm
hearing what you're saying um and
perhaps after we talk about the roads um
I would like to at the risk of causing
unintended
consequences um talk a little bit more
broadly about how you know if we have
resources that are underutilized but we
have a really big need over here and
we're not allowed to um it's worth a
conversation to see if we can um you
know there there could have been a very
specific reason um in 2003 that they
were set up separately but here we are
and we have over 200 miles of roads and
culverts are very expensive and there's
engineering involved and that's that
fund is never going to be enough um so
perhaps we can hear a little specific
about the roads fund and then talk about
what is possible to balance this
out all right thank you so uh let's go
to roads then which is number
221 right uh so as the commissioner rly
pointed out it is another separate
endowment with a specific purpose in
mind this was again established at $1.25
million uh in funds from TPL and the
Society of protection of New Hampshire
forests for the purpose of of ensuring a
Perpetual sourcer of funds to maintain
the system of roads that exists within
the easement and property interests
acquired by the state in the Connecticut
Elite Headwaters tract so again very
spec each one is is clarified with a
specific intent but we are
seeing uh the need to possibly
consolidate or have the latitude to
overlap for example the monitoring
endowment um which was to ensure a
perpet ual source for monitoring
compliance with the terms and conditions
of the
easement is over $3
million um it would be it would be good
for us to be able to divert some of that
available resource to the other
components of the of the stewardship of
this area specifically the road
maintenance um so it would be helpful to
be able to do that what's the balance on
all right could could I just yes
represent you just uh spoke of TPL and
which I don't know what that stands for
and the society for I'm Sor Trust for
Public Lands Trust for Public Lands
that's a national one isn't
it the Trust for Public Lands um I
believe
is is that specifically a a national
National National non
yeah and the society for protection of
forests is unique to New Hampshire
correct this Cas what brought us
back our
trees from total disaster um
and and they do they hold the
supervision of the state easement or why
did you mention them
I I was just clarifying for you the
source of the funds that established
these endowments in the case of yeah
they provided the funds correct in the
case of the monitoring endowment uh
Trust for Public Lands provided the 1.25
million in the case of the stewardship
endowment it was a com it was
a combination of the nature
conservancy and and the trust Republic
lands and then for the uh road
maintenance endowment was a combination
of of funding from the trust for public
lands and the society for the protection
of Hampshire forests
wow so they have some kind of
legal ability to oversee what we're
doing with these don't they uh I'm not
entirely sure I don't think so I think
they just um believed in the cause and
chipped in so that there would be these
These funds
established um I I don't I don't need to
um okay per I don't need to run the
easement by them you know in terms of
like the annual operating plan or the
management plan they they're not I think
it was just part of their mission to
help establish the
funds so we're under a a third now of
our land in Lebanon which is conserved
is is under them we left because it and
are working with another group because
they're easier to
to work with but
um and they were
extremely
um we had to spend a huge amount of
money at one point when someone broke an
easement on one of those yeah and we
could not force him without about four
years of lawyers to uh get out of of our
property no they don't have any clause
management so is there any legal reason
why we couldn't combine these three
dedicated funds into a single Endowment
for the Connecticut headquarters tract
and let
you use them as necessary for different
kinds of projects uh well I think that I
think primarily the the legal reason why
we have them separate is because they
were designated specifically each with
its own AR RSA designation so we'd have
to seek to revise the RSA to allow that
combin yes
yeah Senator gray are we sure that the
money when it was endowed to us didn't
have these three funds set up because if
it did then you got to go back through
the AG and petition the courts to be
able to change it I no but it sounded
like it was the state allocated the
money to create these endowments yes it
wasn't like endowed by Rockefeller or
something the state provided the
authority to allow us to proceed with
getting endowments established and then
the sources of
funding were brought forward to actually
fund the endowments themselves so in the
case of each the trust Republic lands is
in each one of them but in the case of
one the nature conserv has contributed
some funding in the case of another of
the Society of protection of New
Hampshire Forest oh I see um I'm not
sure if there would be any concern or
consideration over the fact that the
society for New Hampshire protection
Forest gave their their part towards
road maintenance so if the state were to
now say we're not Discerning anymore
between these functions it's all all to
the good of any of them wherever it's
needed I don't know if there might be
any into consideration to allow the
donors who who gave the money at the
time to you know need to be able to say
well we gave it for this but we didn't
give it for that that commissioner can
you
comment I wasn't here um when these
conversations uh were originally had um
but I think we need to do a little
homework to figure out what strings
perhaps were attached or promises made
to for each of the funds um so there's a
there's a legal path here but there's
also a political path um
I think the good news is um by the time
there's a new legislative session we
will have I believe we will have
successfully um worked out um negotiated
and and concluded our negotiations with
Aurora to establish the the 10-year
management plan I think that's a great
time to have an overlapping conversation
about how we're going to fund the
stewardship of this property and and
road maintenance is really key to um the
promise of Public Access it's also key
to get around to do the monitoring um so
it does all tie together I think we have
some leg work to do to figure out the
logistics to see if it's POS if there's
a path forward um and and talk through
any unintended consequences and there's
also a narrative that we would have to
share with some of these stakeholders
who have um been very um interested in
the future of this
property all right so that'll be a task
for you I guess
um other comments from the
committee no okay good all right so
you're going to get us um more
appropriate um paperwork here right yes
I'm going to enhance these this report
to include a section that will reflect
the actual endowment that we've
discussed today including the figures
related to the endowment yes all right
thank you so um all right now I have a
note here that uh um Miss mapelli would
like to talk to us
about
[Music]
accounts so this this is seate any any
further questions for dncr on I may have
some we all right hold on a second so
I I wrote notes on things that I thought
um were either useful to understand what
heritage
is has got a major funding problem it
looks like or rather a problem which is
growing
uh and I was wondering about whether you
have the opport ability to increase the
developer
fees which seems to be the only place
the money could come
from uh which fund are you talking yeah
this is on
61224 Au
3407 Bureau of natur natural heritage
which is all by itself towards the end
of
the
spreadsheet 34 oh yeah inreasing
developer fees oh all right number 240
yeah on page 26 of my
report so they do the as far as I know
the main place that they get money from
is that developers decide that they want
to build something on land that is
relatively undisturbed and um that they
are required by our law to to go and get
the bureau to tell them
whether there's something that needs to
be protected in there yeah this is page
26 this is page 26 of 36 in your
report yes and the the funding source is
clarified on page 27 under RSA 217 87a
Section 1 essentially the the funding
this is funded primarily by fees that
are charged as you've described um when
developers or interested parties go on
to certain land they have to uh inquire
as to whether or not there are any
concerns or consideration that might
disrupt the natural habitat areas so
they need to make inquiry in doing so
there is a fee associated with that um
in order to provide that reporting and
information if it comes back that there
is concern or consideration we do
collect the the fee for that inquiry um
and that goes through the Environmental
Services um does does that clarify the
answer the question well it looks to me
like your fees are in your rules right
they're not in law they're they're
defined in rules the rules clarify what
the cost of the fees so for examp these
fees are inadequate because the fund
looks like it constantly has a negative
balance then you might have to change
your R I believe the bureau
administrator would agree wholeheartedly
with you in fact as I understand it they
are seeking to make a rules change to
increase the fees substantially at time
that is true we're working closely with
Dees to to make sure we're appropriately
in what is fair market on this um uh and
we've had productive conversations with
um commissioner Bob Scott and Adam crepo
um to to a commitment to work through
this together so I'm
hoping that sooner rather than later we
will have an opportunity to make that
case
thank you all right any other questions
on this or other
map uh well the historic sites fund is
perpetually uh but it is in better shape
now because it has robbed money from the
state park
fund but um
so they are starting to get enough money
to make some improvement
to places that frequently are just they
try to keep the mold down yeah and we
we've benefited from some arpa funding
to make improvements at specific
historic sites which will be really
helpful um it gave us you know that that
boost um uh so so those projects are you
know are are the contracts are being
wrapped up right now so that we hit the
deadline um and that'll help I think
with revenue and Longevity um but yeah
historic sites I think there's a lot of
opportunity as a history major I think
there's a lot more opportunity um uh
with these sites uh but they do need a
constant amount of work anyone who owns
a old house would understand that
clearly yes all right let's move on to
the treasurer thank you very much thank
department thank you Mr chairman I won't
I won't take uh time I I just um the
note that you receiv received is um we
the treasury is trying to do some
cleanup of the RSA um of the dedicate
account so um you heard us talking about
the off book accounts so we have a a
plan to first of all put those off book
accounts in the accounting system with
the um with the upgrade of the the new
accounting system um there is a there's
a functionality there's a module that
will be able to um move those
essentially put them in the accounting
system but we will have a special
treatment uh so that's a plan for next
year but part of that is we're trying to
figure out what's already in the
accounting system what is not and and
the the correct place where they they
should be um recorded So this is part of
the cleanup we have we have about 30
something accounts of book and and those
some of them are accounts really that at
some point agencies asked us to open
special accounts or investment accounts
for those those are the type of accounts
that we are putting back into the
regular business of the state we're not
going to have special accounts for those
uh we only would like to keep um
essentially separate what our trust in
escco accounts and custodial accounts
things are shouldn't be part of gu they
need to be treated differently so uh so
part of that cleanup we're trying to
identify by um those accounts in already
in RSA
612 um they are called dedicated
accounts and there's another section
that are called trusting agency accounts
and there's another one that's called uh
trusting um escrow and so so we want to
clean those up there are some accounts
are not there others that should be
removed because no longer exist bottom
line is we're working on that cleanup
and and and and my hope is as part of
your agenda we're able to provide you
with um a recommendation a draft of what
should look the law should look like and
perhaps that's something this committee
could consider as part of the work that
you do so if there is time still in your
in your schedule of this dedicated funds
committee uh I would love to come back
and and show you or work with you to to
um to see even I mean I have some ideas
of what how that should look like but
perhaps you have other but you know
again part of your your what you do your
objectives happy to work with you uh
with this work but but I think it will
be important to have a clear definition
in the law of what should be kept
separate uh or or you know if we're
going to have investment accounts for
those we we can still have those but
there are others that simply need to go
back their their the funds that they
just agencies need to put it back into
their business and we shouldn't have
anything uh special for them so would
you be ready in about two weeks to
suggest legislation I could I could I
could have some type of draft and again
can show it to you again it's just what
I think should look like but again I'm
happy to work with you and your in your
thoughts your Visions as to how those
accounts really should Bel where they
belong like I said some of them are we
have special accounts and accounting or
the um State's Financial STS are are
presented as feary funds but they're
listed right now as just a typical dedic
accounts so those are the ones that
again it's a simple cleanup but I'll be
happy to share that with you yeah so
come up with a list right in in about
two weeks I think and we'll work out a a
meeting dat represent W me yeah there is
one that I've been dealing with since I
started this process 20s something years
ago on the government of Japan because
we
facilitated on the process of of coming
to a a
treaty uh with was it Korea at the time
uh on gave
us the money to plant cherry trees
around New
Hampshire and that sat there for a very
long time uh after they planted a bunch
of them and uh it was still there when I
was
looking at it and it got turned somehow
into an account to
allow uh three members of state
government to decide that one or another
um employee of the state was worthy of
getting a small
Grant which seemed very
peculiar and and I don't know how they
achieved that they're hardly using the
money by the way um but um I don't know
how they achieved changing it over like
that when it was a trust from the
government of Japan
um
but there it is I don't know what you do
with something like that that that's a
great question person alme um so that's
a that's an account we have in in and
I'm a member of the board so you are
correct we there's not a lot of activity
in that account um one of the work again
this is this is just cleanup work but
one of the work for that for that boore
is really to define a purpose re review
exactly that is correct that is my
understanding that's what the fund is
for uh but one of the things that um
that department of justice has suggested
is we need to really clarify objectives
of that fund so there's an opportunity
to to Really reestablish or or or review
the mission of that fund um and and
Define it and so we can proceed with a
correct policy um so
there will be more work on that for sure
at least be given to the state
Nursery the the the other one that um
just just briefly uh the other one that
I think in the past I've reported to you
uh was the is the Ben Thompson trust
fund that that fund um requires some
change this requires a review but also
um because of the way the law is written
a very old law um so that needs to re
revised so I've been having conversation
with Department of Justice charal trust
and also with the university system of
New Hampshire and right now what we
would like to do is is essentially um we
we have a plan to move that fund to the
university system endowment so they will
oversee the endowment follow the will of
Ben Thompson um in and again it will be
managed uh probably more appropriately
um so right now we're in the work so
there are two things that need to happen
with that one is Department of Justice
and there needs to be a court proceeding
the other one is to repeal the law so I
already started um with through the
process of house bill to to the agency
budget process we at least um we are
recommending to repeal the laws related
to Ben Thompson so you'll see that work
um when you deal with the budget um but
um but if not that would have been
another work uh apprpriate work for this
this committee to to review but in case
if Ina if if things don't go well with
House Bill too perhaps um you know we'll
can have a discussion again because I
think um all parties that I've had
conversations with are in favor of this
plan and it sounds like it would be a
good path for providing this funds to
the university system they'll manage it
just like they do um any of you know
their endowments that they hold
so right thank you all right so we'll
we'll schedule something um
offline for when our next meting
thank you very much for done all right
so next I'd like to go uh approve the
minutes of the last two
meetings don't move uh I have I have
some I have a
change a correction or whatever so let's
start with the me the minutes of um
the uh 16th September
16th um on the second
page uh under 6 612 uh fund 178 it's
listed you you wrote School building Aid
it's actually School building authority
uhhuh so I thought it was Aid in one
place
but yeah it's it's well in the book and
all that it's School building
authority um they they approve
applications for Aid or whatever ever
but it anyways it should be Authority um
well given that why I did bold things in
both of these that we needed to look at
no I thought that was a good
idea yeah and this one is obviously not
able to use all the money that the
general fund keeps giving
it
right right exactly so um
that one I have kind of an action item
5-m yeah 200-m colon 5 yeah okay so
those are the only changes I had anybody
else
well I was uh I did put a lot of these
in Bolding to see if people agreed or
disagreed with different ideas that had
come up um the first first one is the
second item on page two uh yes they
would be
on the 137 is the board of lure of
interpreters for deaf and Harden hearing
on
and they have they are just allowing the
the money in that fund to grow uh
without doing anything with it well just
and they they did say at the time that
they would be fine with moving that over
to oplc which is good at at
um uh
streamlining no I I I approve of the
Bolding and I we will be talking about
actions in a moment oh so we're doing
but as far as approving the minutes okay
as minutes okay all right so any other
changes all right all those in favor say
I I I any opposed no okay unanimous now
the other one September
18th um I only noticed one little thing
here let's
see uh this is a long one so under the
State
Library uh which is
like the third from the end yeah
something like that um
heard from the end right I had a note
that on on fund 6121
179 um that uh I had a note that the the
title or the it references something
called The Family Resource connection
yes they said that they had stopped
doing that that's right and so I have a
note that uh we we mentioned that we
should check RSA 2011- a Col
10 um and and possibly
delete uh this reference to Family
Resource connection as a defunct term
a yeah okay I didn't realize that was
motion okay second all right all those
in favor say I I any poos all right
anounce all right good now as far as
timing um do we want to kind of go
through the spreadsheet
and uh see what kind of actions should
be in in any bill that comes from this
committee or any other bill that members
might want
to to do
um do we have time right now does or do
people want to come back and do that
some other time all right we why don't
we do that now all
right so um I would like to point out
that I did not always put on
the this one I did put on the
sheet
okay all right so so starting with um
banking I don't think there's any
change
right then Veterans Home same
thing those all seem
good then Department of Education so we
have the one we just talked about move
to
is that something we can all do as a
committee uh send this licensure and
certification fund to
hb2 well or like I said it could be in
our bill yeah yeah file a bill okay all
right so that's that's that one that's
fund number uh 137 yeah now I noticed
you have yellow on 167 but I didn't have
any notes to make any
changes uh well the yellow see that's
you don't I think what see
here yeah I removed all those in the
end U 167 two small dormant private
trust funds oh this is the hat and
Harriet yeah yeah the hat and the
Harriet okay um and and they say they
can't send them over to
unnh even though they're sending another
one
over um so maybe this is in the same
category as the Cherry treat but what
they're talking about is writing rules
to set up a joint grant
program uh themselves which
seems kind of ridiculously
expensive or um just pulling the money
and sending it to the two State
University and State College uh on from
the trusts every year for scholarships
okay which would fit in pretty well with
the intent of the donors okay I guess
not pooling it they'd have to do them
separately because one of them is just
ke and the other one is Kan and pus all
right so I'll make a note to check
whether they need need any RSA help in
order to do that right so so
interest to
scholarships okay
all right next there was one above that
the private trust account for all kinds
of assistance the legally blind yes
which has
been growing it's up to was up to
$686,000 in
2020 um had grown
50% since
2020 and um the trouble is that there
are all sorts of groups working in this
area and so they and they don't probably
give it much
attention
uh right but you have this note the
department will look for ways to set up
grant program they said that they they
try to do that I don't know whether
they're going to or not but that seemed
good enough to me but okay anybody else
just leave it like
that you even got the Secretary of State
V Mach stuff for for blind people so
plenty of places
expended got to be done future in sight
is always trying to get money out of
me that's the main nonprofit that does
things like send my father this
incredible machine that allowed him to
read for a while
longer and my and my father was also in
was in Handover
so all right
but
um okay so so then yeah go ahead yeah
then
um there was this teacher competency
thing which they are very occasionally
using to send someone to a
conference where are we it's on between
138 and and the two dormant funds it's
just below it snuck
together and they say they'll try to
figure out
um more uses for
it which is all kind of vague and oh
fund 139 okay fine education is not very
organized MH in fact if you look at at
their
statutes as has been done by the people
uh at the head
of
of on legislative
services
organized I see the statutes contain
things going back 150
years that make no sense today so they
need a recodification and new chapter
yes well that's beyond my uh right it's
beyond here but it's still anything that
can be done that sends some of this
stuff to places where it can be used
more easily
is
okay right so this
one I what you're saying this one has
low expenses but a slowly growing
balance yeah right right and it's
another private trust fund that we
can't change we can only
redirect
what
wow but if it was just the RSA that
right
was was that a other than our own law
was that a
say oh
my right so it sounds like somebody just
made a decision that yeah they wanted to
support teachers and here was a
convenient source of money right so yeah
okay one thing I can think of
is sending it
to sending out a notice to to teacher
training schools that this money is
available to help the students certify
MH
okay but uh all right let's go on to the
next page here so um then the next one
was the school building authority we
talked about which uh we we previously
said we should get rid of in laps this
to the general fund because it's getting
it's basically getting money and never
has no expenses for five years right
okay so that one
will um
yeah yeah now the the one after that
they are now use getting people to use
teachers that um spent their
lives uh in
AT&T telephone program and are very good
at Computing as in our
major and um and retraining them on
briefly through at to how to teach to
young students and getting them into the
school system
which seems like a useful thing to do at
this
point so they're thinking that
that that program that they only
developed recently is going to increase
the number of teachers and therefore um
they will be able to to use it on the
number of teachers coming in
I guess there will be enough people that
yeah well the problem was the end of
half because there weren't as many
teachers but so I guess that that could
stay and we might not see it in five
years as a
problem unlike some of the others of
these right but it has us sure but it
has I mean it's considerable ongoing
revenue and
balance okay that one seemed okay all
right
next um the blind vending machine thing
it seemed like such a small this fun 296
right seemed like such a small
amount
um not to mess with you know I
don't yeah it can just go on as it is
it two two 28 licensing of private
schools right they say their fees are
sent to 125% of cost mhm uh which is a
ruling that doesn't didn't happen with a
lot of places but that education seems
to be going with except that their
expenses exceed the revenues most of the
time and so the end of year balance has
gone down by about a
third in the five years now how can
their expenses exceed the revenues if
you want to ask them I can ask unless
interest all right so we're talking
about fund
225 so maybe the fees were set to 125%
of cost in 20 10 and yeah there a lot
going on and they don't bother to change
yeah I think we'd run into that before
they set them at 125% and then they
don't change it inflation or
anything right but so once again I mean
this one seemed like it um had enough
money in it to last another cycle yeah
right and it does to last another cycle
probably
um could we just make a
blanket uh statement that they ought to
update all of their
fees they should review their fees their
Fe make a adjust exactly all right so
fine in so in our report kind of yeah
okay um
report
fees to
meet
expenses okay right all right good I
would take care of a couple of them I
think
yeah and the the deceased veterans
children yeah right but there aren't
many there aren't very many and where
that
go and they could provide a
larger Grant
or they or you could cut the money the
general fund gives
them
right right so that again that's not
really our thing but yeah uh so maybe
division two yeah general fund not
all right we got the vending ma was the
robotics team yeah that one seem to be
going
not creating as many teams as it is
collecting
money and the IT collects the money
directly from you I
think right so this is GF right I think
750,000 but it hasn't needed quite that
much
that maybe because they're running out
of schools that that do it that
can do it I should imagine to be really
schools all right so again
um we
this 324 324
324 okay so again division
two
reduce
okay we're expecting this to be a tough
budget year so yeah places where we can
reduce a little or
welcome okay very tough budget year
yeah okay
next now this next one's been losing
money
considerably U but they may have
finished what they're doing pretty
much but they I think just got into
internet
connectivity few years
ago but they had all this arpa money for
it
ni right so they did they spent a lot
for ADA compliance I think also I spent
a lot for
armor armoring
oh at the beginning that's what the
whole thing was about at the beginning I
right but in terms
of it it looks like they tend to decide
let's do this kind of project like
internet or whatever and then go find
money for it and use this fund as just
sort of the the checking account
right so I think it's okay maybe yeah
yeah it could
stay okay and then the next one
um has been deleted but not from the 612
list right so that's an obvious one that
we we will put in our
bill
okay
um and the last one you already
mentioned right we already mentioned
we're going to delete that
one
um and I'm going to look it to this one
that's at The X right even though it was
um I'll I'll talk to
science This One X oh The X oh yes fund
X that oh I yeah I'm going to go read uh
51a yeah and see and I'll talk to the
Science and Tech yeah committee and see
if
um anything active is going on here it
had to do with wind offshore wind well
wind yeah it's supposed to be have a
committee the committee has not yet been
formed and the committee on the Marine
training part of it isn't even
in the write up of Bill
it's just something they thought that
maybe they'd be able to
do well well I have a note to go read
on okay so that takes you the 16
right
okay so information TCH no change right
right the only question was whether to
move this technically to the
treasurer Maybe not maybe it's not worth
doing
um it is oh the the rims account well it
already it the rims account is a very uh
complex
computer program
on if you took it away and put it in the
treasury that Dr couldn't
function well no no this one is just to
pay off the bond yeah yeah and the the
treasury
already the the account is in the
treasury right the Dr just figures out
how much it is and ships the money over
to the account
so maybe leave it alone but the
treasurer isn't going to be able to
figure out whether this was the right
amount or not they do come to the ways
and means committees and they say look
this is how much we've gotten and this
is how we calculated how much we right
what we're saving we can send over okay
all right we'll leave it alone all right
next one uh
oplc um
is we need to repeal this uh
61232 right okay that one's all
set um but they've well we need to
repeal a
612 number yeah but they've left pieces
in it about real estate apprais that
have to be somewhere in the state law
and so we don't want to repeal anything
that's actually in the
right the the um RSA
310b that's still there right keep they
okay so it's just the 612 number that
has to
disappear
okay
um
so we don't want to touch 340 or
yeah
um right all right so this off book
thing we might hear from the treasure on
yeah so the next one I got a note on is
um
so uh oh way down there yeah so this one
is the site evaluation committee has
this one employee who's like the matech
repairman he has nothing to do right no
I think that he works in
others he this is a part-time part of
his job exactly so he worked for the Pu
basically right right and there's this
dedicated fund that in case somebody
says I want to build a power plant yeah
then he would swing into action kind of
and they would have to hire a bunch of
other people they would have to hire a
lot of consultants and do a bunch of
stuff so but I'm wondering whether this
guy can just be permanently part of the
Pu and his his accounting be part of the
Pu and not have this dedicated fund so
that's I have a note to look into that
well he did say
that he
he they got rid of the previous person
by uh taking her into another job in
another place on and for a year there
was nobody there and he said that's why
he said that he kept busy last year with
two years of accumulated dockets and
complaints and um so there that function
will still be there very at various
times okay I don't know how much of his
salary they put they put there but
it's the Pu stuff for me is kind of hard
to
yeah to follow well I I will look into
that okay and
then this other
253 which okay is the whole all of the
Reggie money coming
in and it the audited expenses that
$4,275
th000 uh for the five for the five years
but then in the same page below they
list the expenses which total
20,
241,000
and and then they tell us the only place
where they tell us because the breakdown
is for that 20
million 18% was compensating the
department of
energy
uh oh now 18% was compensating
Department of energy and the Department
of Environmental Services for their
expenses 45% was for wood pellet boets
and residential commercial and
Industrial so solar en installation
projects and 37% for competitive grants
for commercial industrial renewable
energy and and low moderate income
program group together and then
2,33
for
and this gives you
no real information on the things that
they say that they're supposed to be be
um
doing how much money went into each
program I see which include the office
of offshore wind and energy Innovation
yet but which also includes solar
projects um a capped uh renewable and
thermal energy projects low moderate
residential separated off um
non-residential
projects
and it really seems pretty much like the
me so do you want to get them back to
ask them more questions or that would be
nice to see if we could get any more
information out of them about how much
of of this is going to each of the the
targets
which which are in the states regie
application that I think is is the ones
I was just listing off okay and to
different parts of it because the parts
are supposed to be responsibly balanced
okay all right well why don't you come
up with a list of questions we'll send
it to them and ask them to come in two
okay and the the other parts
just pretty much I think live off of
that
money right so so are we talking about
272 um I'm talking about 253 because
that's where they got into more
specifics okay but the specifics don't
add up all right follow me list of
question all right so Jennifer you'll
invite them back once you get the
questions sent yeah okay all right
so anything else pu um
energy Energy
Efficiency yeah I
didn't okay see any particular problem
or that that all fuels thing was kind of
weird but it gets sent to New Hampshire
saves
MH all right good
yeah all right so we've we've talked
with them about separating the Canon
skap from the parks I I think it makes
sense all right so we'll add that to
fund okay and they're working on the
issues that I had with the
Connecticut Lakes
Headwaters right endowment right so
they'll work on they'll they'll make
they'll give us an opinion on whether we
can combine those three funds into a
single
one right so therefore they have more
um yeah now you're working off this and
I'm working off of the separate
between programs which made it I thought
would make it easier but all right go
ahead so
um that one
is where Parkson and Rec has 10 funds is
at the beginning of the fifth page
right um and we already discussed that
pretty well
M oh and I did I we should have asked
the treasurer this question we've got
the Hampton meters as a
612 and we have the Hampton meters
inside of an accounting unit in
61233 b as I'm calling it I see so are
we double counting
them I
see so
so where is the Hampton Hampton meters
managing apartment oh so this fun
105 right fund 105 accounting unit 7300
yeah right so what it your note
says the first 200,000 goes into this
33 so that's why it's in fund 33 fund 33
is the main one yeah right 133 is the
main one so so by
law 200,000 is specific lead to to uh
fund
with with only 200,000 a year being
showing up in in fund 105 yes but back
on 33
says should be separated
so yeah we want to separate if you're
fund from have the funds go back to 33
then you need to say what part of 33
right it's the state parks it's it's not
the SK area yeah right that's why I
talked about the park fund right that's
just to show you I was awake then yeah
thank you yeah
okay so um so I think that one's okay
yeah yeah yeah I think they've done a
great job of cleaning
up five years ago this was impossible
right and I have a note on fund 107 the
the mining
permits
to
um read the RSA and see if it if it
needs some
updating um uh you you said should this
fun continued to exist I have should it
geologist so I'm what else the state
geologist does um whether he's
overworked
already yeah and would not appreciate
somebody coming in and asking him if he
can get a mining permit for two acres of
land in North Conway
yeah right so I I I want to go I'll I'll
have an action item to to look into that
a little more all
right
um all right and then on fund 179 the
state librarian we had is it
defunct does the RSA need some
updating are we not there yet the state
librari oh I see we're going in a
um okay well well in any case so we
solve the so so the the parking meters
are okay right yeah okay State library
right yeah isn't that the next one it it
gets 1.5 million a year from the general
yeah it seemed pretty
clear
right so that's that's not related to
this well I mean the general this
dedicated fund doesn't get 1 and a half
million yeah right separate from this
account yeah that's just part of their
budget yeah right yeah that's what keeps
their budget alive that so the next one
102 lost damaged or lost book account
receives
fines I wasn't quite sure from the write
up and what they were telling us the
state librarian was telling us whether
they are getting fines or donations that
is is it voluntary to pay them for the
damage no I think it is fin right
somebody loses the book or whatever lost
in damaged books and brings them back
late
yeah yeah they didn't even mention late
finds no this most of the libraries are
doing away with
them with with the late finds
I mean they still have a good balance
but it is declining yeah because so so
they may have to charge more yeah but he
so
but yeah so that's but I don't think
it's in in law what he charges for for
books right
so well it couldn't be in laws for well
it could be in law for the the cost of a
total repair and that would be Beyond a
number of
blenders well if you want me to I will
go read the
law um which would be read okay
[Music]
we what was next well you put something
on on 179 the yes I have a note to do
something check 20 1 A10 and delete
delete something I'm not sure what uh
right
okay that's it CU they aren't doing
oh but we we skipped did we skip
Summit the trails Bureau and donations
to state parks we skipped over right but
I didn't have any notes that we wanted
to do anything
yeah yeah I don't
either I think those are okay the only
thing is somewhere but I think I think
it may already have been done to take I
think it was just in their reports
talking about the Dartmouth
College um bonding that they were paying
off which they paid off in
20 right that was a long time yeah it's
irrelevant at this
point all right so then we come
preservation uh the coastal
resilience I have
talked with the sponsor who is David
Waters um about this which one are you
on I'm I'm close to 358 358 yeah it's
been sitting there it was put into law
just before Co hit mhm
and um that made it complicated getting
started but the thing that made it more
complicated getting starting started was
a former Senator uh in his district who
insisted that they invite everybody and
their brother to the
commission uh which made it impossible
to get a
quorum oh it's one of those things that
had a 25 member Mission and yeah or more
and six people show up or something more
um
he he is now on saying that he would
like to bring put some stuff together
maybe I don't know if he could do it in
the next two weeks who are we talking
about um this is David
Waters um because a number of the town
have on their own because of this being
an important issue for them I see have
come up with different
projects and he thinks that some kind of
coordinating of that would be
useful so he may bring it in next year
as a separate bill or he might have
something together in time to come and
talk to us about it okay
going within within this framework sure
okay but um they are getting serious
erosion on the coast
MH and a lot of
historic buildings and things sit on the
coastal Shores
them all right but our default is
probably to get rid of this fund
regardless right okay the default would
be just just get rid of the fund and the
towns came in and maybe get some FEMA
grants yeah well part of it has been
they've gotten a little bit of FEMA
grants I think they got a little of our
money and things like that but
um I think yeah I think that that fund
is not going to work
so but he I think he'd like
to figure out pieces of the statute that
could be kept in order to
uh help the towns organize themselves on
this more than they're doing right
now and he admits he dropped the ball
and after Co started to fade
got all right so I told them I'd bring
it
up all right and so um then on fund 240
we've already they already talked about
raising their fees
right I think um yeah we've we've talked
and commissioner right because this this
is the one where we said their fees are
in their rules and they were they're
right working on changing it so do I
think this one is
okay as long as they don't raise them
too much developers are building AR all
right so I think we're done yeah all
right I think so too
imagine all right let's talk about the
next
meeting to do clean up and maybe have a
here the afternoon of Wednesday October
16th
that's a Wednesday right Wednesday so
far I've got a 12 to 2
p.m. down here
oh and then you want to have lunch so
then well I think it probably has lunch
in it oh okay so you could start at 2
p.m.
yeah is that okay Cent so far okay all
right when are we when are we schedule 2
P.M
Wednesday October
16th 17th is it I have 16 which day you
said Wednesday the 16th oh it is the
16th yeah is that right is that
different for you
or o' Wednesday 16th okay great all
right any other
business all right we're adjourned thank
you okay good so once I'm going to
adjourn but which clock are you going to
use my own 35 okay or
than
e